hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV we
are at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and
we're talking with Pasha Roberts the man
the author behind silver circle tell us
about your film project Pasha we're
working on this movie called silver
circle but instead of yet now the
documentary is actually a narrative is
the story of set in 2019 about rebels
fighting the Federal Reserve okay and
it's an animated folks animated movie
yeah feature-length and it said just
this kind of cool story about this cat
and mouse game between a Federal Reserve
investigator and these cool group of
rebels it's all set in DC actually there
a lot of it happens in dupont circle so
what are what kind of effect are you
hoping to have what kind of results are
you trying to achieve with the release
of the movie basically we show heavy
economic collapse following basic
policies we have now so prices are 20
times what we have now there's all kinds
of other bad events that we're seeing
the economy and the rebels are fighting
against the Federal Reserve both you
know I guess their policies and they
also make their own money out of silver
mm-hmm so what we're really trying to do
is create a cultural injection or bomb
you know we're trying to let it be
something that libertarians and silver
people enjoy but we're also going really
heavily into pop culture and comic
conventions so that people just like a
cool story and enjoy a nice game you
know about this get to learn about
something new and it's not heavy handed
there's no 78-page john galt speech but
it's kind of like a neal stephenson type
science fiction scenario right where
Wally okay yeah environmental movie but
it's coated and you know something cool
where the best place is to catch
glimpses of silver circle before it's
before its premiere or release and then
tell us about what's the role and
schedule for the movie sure I mean we um
we've done some years here at Freedom
Fest in a park fest last week those
rooms contain spoilers so those are not
public but we have other trailers that
are up on our website called silver
circle movie com and there's a very
active blog very active Facebook group
like 12,000 fans now something like that
we're pushing hard to finish it and
submit it to Sundance in September we're
going also shortly after submitted to
South by Southwest and after you know
after those we roll out to 15 cities
like a limited theatre release kind of
like out this rug started out with all
right back but maybe use the same
releasing company will see okay cool
well Pasha Roberts the man behind silver
circle an animated movie about [ __ ] bad
monetary policy with a science fiction
twist thanks so much for talking to us
great thank you Nick for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie